MICHEL DEGRAFF: So critical
computational empowerment.
That's one of the key concepts
that Professor Fox Harrell, who
was one of our guest speakers,
discussed during his visit
to class.
And it was a big
hit in the class.
Because, as you know,
we have many engineers,
scientists in the course.
And many of them are so used
to the notion of coding,
of computation, being
supposedly neutral
when it comes to ideology.
And to the societal tendencies.
But what Fox should
really clearly is
that those hierarchies of power,
that this course is about,
really, are themselves
embedded in these codes.
In these codes that create
video games, virtual reality
platforms.
So if we're not aware
of these hierarchies,
and how they are coded--
really coded-- in
those platforms,
then we become prey to
them without even knowing.
We accept their
assumptions, and we
reinforce our own attitudes
that might put down women,
or immigrants, or
Muslims, or gay people.
So we will become part
of these hierarchies
and maintaining them.
But also what Fox
showed in his visit is
that, once you understand
how coding can encode
those hierarchies,
then we can actually
create codes that
will, in turn, give us
more flexibility for identities
that are more inclusive.
And more humane towards,
especially, women,
and blacks, and Latinos,
and Muslims, et cetera.
So the one thing that
Fox did in his visit
was to show us one
of his platforms
where he brings together
people on different sides
of a conflict.
So one case that he
showed was this conflict
between the Israelis
and the Palestinians.
So there's this perform where
you can bring those soldiers
together, who fight
on opposite sides,
and through that, they
get to better empathize
with each other's
identities, and biographies,
and life circumstances.
So that was really a powerful
concept for the students
to get to understand.
How coding can indeed help us
code a better world for all.